dans l'immensité silencieuse du ciel
étoilé une menace invisible rode un trou
noir à 16 millions de milliards de
kilomètres Gaïa BH1 le plus proche de
notre terre trop loin pour être
dangereux non soyez pas si sûr les trous
noirs se font dans l'obscurité quasi
indétectable sinon par l'influence
qu'ils ont sur leur environnement on
joue pas l'un de r peut être à proximité
car oui un trou noir ça bouge certains
se propagent à plus de 175 000 km/h par
rapport au centre de leur galaxie
imaginons qu'un trou noir s'invitait aux
portes de notre système solaire que se
passerait-il où va-t-on se faire aspirer
y a-t-il un moyen de l’arrêter on vous
explique comment survivre à un trou noir
un trou noir dans le système solaire ça
ferait quoi mauvaise nouvelle on y
survivrait pas enfin ça va dépendre de
sa taille il existe quatre types de
trous noirs les primordiaux
hypothétiques avec une masse de quelques
microgrammes les stellaires jusqu'à 14
fois plus massives que le soleil les
intermédiaires et les super massifs se
nichent au cœur des galaxies le plus
grand est théoriquement Phénix Astar un
monstre de cette taille perturberait du
soleil des 1000 années-lumière modifiant
de même celle de toutes les planètes
l'une et astéroïdes vous dans certains
temps il engloutirait tout le système
solaire formant un gigantesque disque
d'accrétion autour de lui un amarotatif
de gaz et de poussière tournant à une
vitesse avoisinante celle de la lumière
et une température pouvant atteindre des
milliards de degrés doux et manerait des
radiations mortelles cela dit nos
chances de survie ne seraient pas
meilleur avec un trou noir stellaire
disons trois masses solaires le minimum
théorique imaginons qu'il soit au port
de notre système solaire trop loin pour
être dangereux pas vraiment à moins de
deux années lumière de nous il causerait
un désordre gravitationnel dans le nuage
d'orques des milliards de milliards de
débris qui forment un mur nous
protégeant du reste de l'univers là il
serait projeté dans tous les sens et on
se prendrait quelques astéroïdes ce
n'est pas tout à mesure qu'il
s'aventurer vers le système solaire ce
dernier serait irrémédiablement attiré
vers lui à cause du champ gravitationnel
qu'il exerce qu'adviendra-t-il de nous
éjecter de sa trajectoire habituelle la
terre sortirait de la zone habitable il
ferait tout d'un coup très très froid et
nous n'aurions pas le temps de nous
plaindre car le pied reste à venir
l'attraction intense du trou noir
provoquerait la fissuration de la croûte
terrestre causant tremblement de terre
éruption volcanique et tsunami
apocalyptique il ne resterait plus de
notre planète qu'une surface terrible
pavée de magma et le soleil dans tout ça
plusieurs scénarios sont possibles selon
sa vélocité sa proximité et sa direction
dans le meilleur des cas le soleil
graviterait au tour sinon il serait
propulsé hors de son orbite ordinaire
vers un voyage sans fin au confins de
l'espace la situation la moins favorable
pour lui serait d'être déchiqueté par
les forces de marées du trou noir il ne
serait plus qu'un disque d'accrétion
seul témoin de son existence passée
rassurez-vous on n'a qu'une chance sur
40 milliards d'en rencontrer un soit la
probabilité de gagner au loto 3 fois de
suite mais si ça nous arrivait il
faudrait s'y préparer comment détruire
un trou noir 4 solutions sont
envisageables d'abord lancer toutes nos
bombes nucléaires dessus on pourrait le
faire exploser non malheureusement ce
n'est pas si simple un trou noir est
intangible il n'a pas de surface
physique pour le comprendre il faut
remonter à sa création une général
massif meurt elle est si lourde qu'elle
s'effondrer elle-même courbant ainsi
l'espace-temps toute sa masse sera
concentré dans un point théoriquement
infiniment petit la singularité cette
immense boule noire n'est qu'une
illusion un pourtour immatériel
l'horizon des événements dont la gravité
est ici intense que la lumière elle-même
ne peut y échapper voilà pourquoi nos
bombes n'aurait aucun effet elle serait
attirée au centre piégé à tout jamais se
rajoutant à sa masse par la même
occasion deuxième solution neutraliser
le trou noir avec un autre trou noir
pour commencer il faut réussir à en
créer un et ce n'est pas une mince
affaire en théorie la collision de
particules très haute énergie dans des
accélérateurs comme le LHC pourrait bien
engendrer des trous noirs mais les
conditions nécessaires à leur création
sont extrêmement rares sans compter
qu'il serait microscopique et tout à
fait inoffensif avec une masse de
l'ordre de quelques microgrammes
tellement petit qu'il s'évaporerait
presque instantanément dans un éclair de
lumière semblable au sapin de Noël pour
obtenir un trou noir de taille à
affronter l'intrus qui nous menace
disant une masse solaire il faudrait
condensé une énorme quantité de matière
dans un espace très petit en gros
comprimé plusieurs fois notre soleil
dans une sphère de 6 km de diamètre ce
processus nécessiterait une quantité
d'énergie phénoménale que seule une
technologie hypothétique pour régénérer
en plus il faudrait trouver la manœuvre
adéquate pour le maintenir hors de notre
portée pour éviter qu'ils nous
engloutissent à son tour de la
science-fiction à ce stade et
heureusement pour nous car le résultat
escompté de leur collision serait
catastrophique si effectivement on
parvenait à créer un trou noir puis le
lancer sur l'ennemi les deux
commenceraient d'abord par graviter l'un
autour de l'autre dans une danse spirale
infernale se rapprochant de plus en plus
au bout d'un certain temps le couple
finirait par fusionner formant un plus
grand trou noir plus massif encore et
plus dangereux dévié de sa trajectoire
initiale ce qui ne ferait que compliqué
notre situation troisième solution
attendre en 1975 le célèbre
astrophysicien Stephen Hawking démontre
qu'un trou noir et susceptible de
s'évaporer par l'émission de rayonnement
conformément à la physique quantique
n'importe quel point de l'espace
contient une paire de et antiparticules
d’énergie opposée dès leur apparition
celles-ci se heurte aussitôt pour
s’annuler mutuellement c'est là que les
choses deviennent intéressantes et si
cette paire apparaissait juste au bord
de l'horizon des événements en théorie
l'une des particules échappées à
l'attraction du trou noir tandis que son
homologue tomberait dedans les
particules évadés formeraient le fameux
rayonnement de Hawking quant aux
particuliers plus le trou noir
n'absorberait plus il perderait de
l'énergie ce qui ferait diminuer sa
masse avec le temps jusqu'à le faire
disparaître complètement alors on aurait
qu'à attendre oui mais prenons notre mal
en patience cela n'arriverait pas avant
un suivi de 67.0 en pour un trou noir
super massif assez pire ce processus
pourrait atteindre un gogolan un trou
noir hypothétique pesant seulement le
poids d'une montagne soit 1000 milliards
de kilogrammes qui disparaîtrait au bout
de 3 millions d'années mais vu que
l'univers est vieux de 13,8 milliards
d'années en principe tous les trous
noirs formés à la nuit des temps ce
serait dissipés pourtant aucun phénomène
de la sorte n'a été observé à ce jour
délire d'ingénier ou non attendent
l'évaporation d'un trou noir n'est
clairement pas une sage décision il nous
reste alors une qui est derrière
solution détruire le trou noir grâce aux
maths en 1965 rocker et Ezra Ted Newman
on combiné leur savoir pour élaborer un
théorème la métrique de kernum ici un
trou noir ne peut exister que si ça
masse ça charge électrique et sa
rotation autour de lui-même elle vérifie
la formule suivante ce n'est qu'en 2010
que nos 2 0 interviennent Ted Jacobson
et Thomas sotirius se sont penchés sur
la question en publiant un article
entièrement dédié à la destruction des
trous noirs selon la relativité générale
si les paramètres du trou noir vérifient
l'équation inverse ce dernier
deviendrait instable et perdrait son
horizon des événements de laissant
derrière lui qu'une singularité nue
inoffensive neutre salut est enfin à
portée de main mais pas si vite hein car
pour y parvenir il conviendrait soit de
le surcharger au max soit de le faire
tourner plus rapidement le tout en
veillant à ce que ça masse reste la même
inutile de préciser que d'un point de
vue technologique la première option est
la plus simple en pratique ça
reviendrait à gaver le trou noir de
particules hautement électrique jusqu'à
ce que leur charge dépasse sa masse il
n'y a qu'un seul candidat que nous
connaissons des protons ceux qu'on
trouve au cœur des atomes combien ils
nous en faut on a calculé à votre place
environ 4000 sextilions protons soit 20
fois le nombre d'étoiles présentes dans
l'univers comment s'y prendre c'est là
que les choses deviennent complexes au
fond du cernes se cache le LHC une méga
structure hors-norme dédiée à la
collision des particules la source pour
générer des protons serait une simple
bouteille d'hydrogène gazeux connecté à
une machine appelée Linéa C4 un
accélérateur linéaire surpuissant
inauguré en 2017 puis suivant un procédé
compliqué dont vous épargner des tailles
un faisceau de protons se réformé pour
alimenter un autre engin qui va
l'accélérer à la vitesse de la lumière
la victoire est à nous il nous suffirait
juste de projeter ce rayon de protons
sur le trou noir affamé à une telle
vitesse pour le désamorcer en moins de 2
ans le temps qui lui parvienne entre
temps même si ce dangereux vortex se
déplaçait à la plus grande vitesse
observée d'un trou noir il n'aurait
parcouru qu'un dixième de millièmes de
la distance qui nous sépare nous voilà
sauver l'humanité aurait réalisé le plus
grand exploit de son existence mar à
jamais sachez tout de même que cette
opération aurait coûté 20 000 milliards
d'euros en comparaison l'ISS qui se
classe dans le livre des Guinness en
tant que l'objet le plus cher jamais
créé n'a coûté que 140 milliards d'euros
néanmoins la destruction du titre noir
reste purement hypothétique des
chercheurs avancent qu'il se peut que
l'objet revienne à son espace stable
sans perdre le moment cinétique ou la
charge électrique reçue mais s'il se
défait effectivement de son horizon des
événements ceux-ci sous les vrais une
perspective passionnante celle d'exposer
une singularité nue dans toute sa
splendeur nous pourrions enfin
contempler l'infini malheureusement ce
phénomène n'a jamais été observé dans
l'univers bien que des modèles
informatiques et trouver un cas
particulier ou une étoile implosante lui
donnerait naissance car cette vidéo n'a
vraiment pas été facile parce que
personne n'en avait encore parlé à part
dans des papiers scientifiques
compliqués on espère avoir tout bien
retranscrit un grand merci à Martin
Fournier Eric Lagadec et aussi à
scienceclic de nous avoir partagé leurs
connaissances et d'avoir participé à
cette vidéo pensez à vous abonner et à
liker allez les amis Ciao